Another Blessing Allah has given us is
brother Oscar alhamdulillah giving us
the honor of um of helping him give take
his shahada live for everybody inshallah
to benefit from as well it's always a
beautiful Iman booster salaam alaikum
how you doing I'm grateful well like
walaikum
you're looking good thank you thank you
okay so I'm sure like maybe y'all are
curious or some of the viewers are kids
like why is he wearing a headdress you
know and he's not even Muslim yet and
there's a story behind that too but I
want to take my shahada right now so I'm
ready I'll take it in Arabic first and
then English all right
before we say that she had that I'm just
going to ask you six very quick
questions about like the tenets of faith
in Islam so first and foremost we do
believe that there's only one God worthy
of worship with no Partners or
Associates yes 100 and do you believe in
the angels of Allah 100 yes and do you
believe in the prophets and Messengers
that Allah has sent yes 100 and do you
believe in the revelations that Allah
has sent with the messengers like the
Torah the gospel and the Quran
yes and do you believe in decree Divine
decree or destiny from Allah
yes 100 and do you believe in life after
death in the day of judgment
yes and yes 100 Allah Allah bless you
immensely and with that being said
can you guys see my screen yes all right
just repeat after me in Arabic
and LA and LA ilaha
illallah
Anna
Anya
muhammadan Muhammad Abu duhu abduhu wa
rasulo rasulu now repeat after me in
English I bear witness I bear witness
that there is none worthy of worship
that there's nothing but worship
none worthy of worship non-worthy of
worship except for Allah except for
Allah and I bear witness and I bear
witness that the prophet Muhammad that
the prophet Muhammad is the servant and
messenger of Allah is these servant and
messenger of Allah Allah
welcome to Islam our beautiful brother
Oscar how are you feeling my man
grateful and excited
so why don't you go ahead and tell us
about your uh your beautiful story in
coming to Islam yeah first I want to
give a shout out to Allah Allah Akbar
and then second I want to give a shout
out to my wife for allowing me and
helping me like give me the space to
tune into the live because we have two
sons and they're two under two so like
it takes more than one person to
definitely take care of them
so I want to give a shout out to her and
then
the story is I've been studying Islam
for like since 2018 but it's not the
Islam that I'm tuning into now it's the
Islam that has been
I guess you could say watered down or
remixed because here in
North America before the United States
it was the 13 colonies and before the 13
colonies it was the Americas before the
Americas it was Northwest of Mexico
and the so-called Indians of here were
not really called Indians that Indian
name was given to them in replacement of
their original name which were the Moors
the Moors the Moorish Empire used to run
majority of the world including over
here in in the Americas so that's why I
wear this turban or I wear a headdress
because sometimes I wear a fast
and first I I did it just to remind
myself and remind other people around
them that where we come from and the
original indigenous people how they used
to look how they used to wear so I would
do that but then after I noticed that
declared because like the reason why I
mainly was attracted to it it had a lot
of answers for the questions that I was
seeking but then once I've noticed that
most of these answers
after cross-referencing it they weren't
accurate in my opinion therefore like uh
because the reason
many people like I don't know if you've
heard about the Moors and like the like
the rise of the Moors or things like
that here in the in the states
no I'm not familiar yeah so many of the
Moors including in Cana land AKA Canada
because Canada used to be called Cano
land so a lot of the more they like to
study history and they like to identify
the country with its older name with the
original name instead of the new
corporate name
and
many of the Moors would say declare your
nationality because nationality is the
order of the day and I'm like what is
declare your nationality mean so I did
further research and that was back in
2018 and then I found found a prophet
named Prophet abujra Ali who
surprisingly he wrote well he didn't
write he prepared the circle seven Holy
Quran have you guys heard of that
uh no so it's not the same as the Quran
that Prophet Muhammad wrote it's a lot
smaller and it's more specific to a
group of people of here in the in the
northwest
or in the so-called United States and
prophetra Ali he wrote or prepared that
book at age 40 just like Prophet
Muhammad wrote the book The Holy Quran
okay can I can I just jump in quickly
please yeah yeah go ahead so
when um
when you say he's a prophet do you mean
like a prophet of God like the prophet
Muhammad and all that or what do you
mean when you say prophet
what I mean with profit he was he was
sent because uh the more as they believe
in Allah as well but it's it's like they
kind of contradict themselves and that's
why I kind of slowed down entertaining
that information because there was a few
contradictions so it is like a prophet
from Allah because he did come to
free the so-called black people by
letting them know hey if you nationalize
and you know and you accept the law as
your God and if you accept that you're
not black and you do have a nationality
you will not have uh you won't be in
trouble with with the jurisdiction of
the United States
yeah so are you talking about like uh is
this kind of the like the Nation of
Islam rhetoric information
completely different the Nation of Islam
I don't participate with them I think
they are instead of disrespecting them I
think they're just through a hard
learning curve all of them they're going
through a hard learning curve because I
don't want to disrespect them in any way
so I don't know I never entertain that
you know especially and ever entertain
them or followed him or put him on a
pedestal so it's different from that
okay so I just I just want to make sure
that this like this Moorish kind of
Islam and all that stuff you don't
believe that there is a prophet after
the prophet Muhammad peace upon him
right so now I said Prophet Muhammad as
the only true prophet and they saw to
Islam and uh like the last and final
prophet in messenger of Allah correct
correct perfect because just to be clear
for like everyone you and the viewers we
believe in the prophets like Abraham
Noah Moses Jesus uh peace and blessings
be upon all of them and the prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings to be upon
him but we believe that the prophet as
Allah says in the Quran is the Seal of
the prophets and in another recitation
of the same Ayah the last of the
prophets so and there are unfortunately
a few different groups that are trying
to say oh this person the prophet that
person Prophet
very clearly as Muslim as Muslims Allah
messenger of Allah so when you know
after learning all this stuff and saying
that there are contradictions and that
stuff when did you come to you know true
Islam
I started studying it consistently for
like the past month or so and the the
funny thing is because I I would
entertain the true Islam like a year ago
but I wasn't really
focusing on it 100 because me and
including many other Moors or declared
Morris would be like oh that's dogmatic
religion we shouldn't be doing that the
higher self is is the god and your lower
self is the devil like you are your own
devil you are like like that's where the
contradictions were coming from you know
and and that's that's when I started to
you know just connect the dots and I was
like okay like if if nationality is the
is the order of the day and many of
these mores were declared to Moors are
saying that
like this is the true Islam but then I
then I started to read the Holy Quran
last year because I I asked for a copy
and then I started to see differences
actually took a photo with my son with
my first son like me reading the Quran
to him because I want to show that photo
to him when he gets older and that was
last year so I was like dabbling last
year but then I started consistently
studying it like a month and I would
just watch y'all's Channel when y'all
were like around 80k subscribers how to
watch other channels another channel is
a the skeptical Muslim I really like his
channel
the Muslim skeptic Daniel yeah him yeah
yeah yeah I really like his his channel
then I would watch uh Muhammad uh hijab
I think yeah yeah so like I really like
how he
uh represents himself and represents
Islam so that's what attracted me more
too so now like I I stopped listening to
music even before I send my shahada
because
I used to listen to everything like it
would be country pop hip-hop classic
hip-hop classical music metal Rock like
everything because I like I didn't have
a specific genre I was open to
everything and now I don't listen to
anything because it's it's a lot better
I'm able to focus more but if I am
listening to anything it would be to
debates it would be the recitation of
the Quran or it would be y'all's Channel
when y'all interview different people so
that's what I really listen to more you
know because I really want to prepare
myself before I took my shahada then I
would uh then the wearing the headdress
is going circling back to like what I
mentioned earlier
this year in the beginning of this year
I made the intention and a promise to
myself that I'm aware of my headdress as
much as I can even at work only to to
make the
a promise for myself that I'ma represent
myself and the indigenous Mexicans that
are from Mexico to let them know like
hey this is how we used to look this is
how we used to be because the original
mexican that are not show or taught in
school like in the history books is uh
needs to be taught needs to be reminded
and if you look at the Virgin Mary she
looks Muslim herself covering her body
from head to toe and if you look and you
Google different photos of like Mexico
from the 1700s or 1600s most of them
look Muslim so that's why I wear the
headdress you know and if I'm if I don't
wear the turban I wear a Fest or if I
could wear it both sometimes I put the
tournament and the Fizz on
Allah
Affairs uh they call it uh in Turkey
it's like a red headdress where ah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah that it has a tassel
it's it's with the Shriners and the
Freemasons wear but the difference of
mine in theirs is my tassel is not
pinned and it it's not marked meaning
I'm free so that's it's my right to wear
that fence but with Freemasons and
Shriners the reason why it's marked and
their tassel is pinned is because
they're slaves to their Master which
were the Moors because a lot of the
Moors
top which a lot of the boys were Muslim
by the way just so y'all know for the
record they were the original Islam like
the Islam that I took my shahada with
they were those Muslims and they would
teach mathematics Linguistics
um and many other things to the
Europeans so they could bring the
Europeans out of the darkness and into
the light you know so they could be
civilized and everything so that's why
there's this Mark and their tassel was
pinned because they only have a limited
degree of knowledge and talking about
Freemasons I did look up some fun facts
that George Washington he didn't believe
in the Trinity and Thomas Jefferson he
bought uh well he he either he bought or
he was gifted to him I think it was
gifted to him a holy Quran uh 11 years
before he wrote the Constitution or
before he created the Constitution so
Islam had a lot to do with the
Constitution that we have today it was
heavily influenced and George Washington
too he allowed his Muslim slaves I mean
this sounds wrong but it's just a
historical fact he allowed his Muslim
slaves to work and to buy themselves out
of being out of slavery so they could be
free and George Washington would would
also learn Arabic from them or learn
some of the Islamic principles from them
and that's why he gave him more freedom
compared to the other slaves from
different religions or different
nationalities
this is real like you have actual like
yeah you don't have to believe me you
you could no I'm not questioning you but
I'm not I'm not Christian like that I'm
just wondering that's what I like about
the Muslim Community or or about Islam
is that we have to look for facts you
know before we actually take it uh as a
fact you know and that's what I really
like about that too I like challenging
because that's how you grow like Allah
says in the Quran like the only way you
can know your true strength is by
testing you know just by testing
yourself or by passing the test or even
if you fail the test you have another
opportunity to to improve and majority
of my life I've always been about
self-improvement but there's like a year
or two or three that I did fall off and
I was like pessimistic I was like you
know what there's no point in improving
like this but I've recently been
disciplined and waking up at 5am every
day even though I go to sleep sometimes
at 12 because I have two two children
two under two one is a year and a half
and another one is like about to be a
month or he's probably a month
I barely get any sleep but I discipline
myself to wake up at five because I want
to start my day before I go to work I
don't want to just wake up and go to
work you know and yeah
we're just talking about these things
yeah literally we just we the whole like
last hour and a half or last hour we
were talking about all this stuff's
trying a lot yeah yeah it's beautiful
it's lining up and and I'm big on
discipline I mean I may sometimes I may
be too harsh like for like for my wife
or for my cousins or anyone that's close
to me like you gotta discipline yourself
and because I don't tolerate like uh
um uh what's the word procrastination
but I do procrastinate myself and that's
why I I get caught up in my own thinking
because I'm like okay I don't tolerate
uh uh like other people's lacking but I
slack a little bit sometimes you know so
like okay I just have to lead by example
and save my energy save my my opinion
until I actually started applying 100 of
discipline and stopped procrastinating
100 yeah I don't know if that's possible
is that possible to stop procrastination
100 percent
um I'd say extremely difficult
you know what it's theoretical unless
like you've actually been through
yourself but theoretically speaking I
think I think it would be uh granted the
right situation is put into place like
if you have a man and he has like
several wives and several children I
highly doubt this man's gonna be
procrastinating
right
yeah because uh because I like well I've
been told from many people that I'm hard
on myself like I have to like be softer
to myself but I really don't see that
you know like I can't really comprehend
that because it's coming from my own
perspective but I really can't see that
however uh circling back to the story so
after it's consistently studying like a
month and a half consistently back to
back watching different debates
listening to the Quran and reading it
I'm like okay like I have a few
questions about a few things but I know
I'm gonna get the answers the more I
read the Quran you know so like because
all the answers are there because if I
just ask y'all or someone else that's
just me procrastinating on reading the
Quran you know instead of looking for
the answers myself yeah 100 actually on
that note we have a super chat uh
brother Mo says welcome to Islam Oscar I
strongly urge you to study the Quran and
the Sera which is the life of the
Prophet sallallahu alaihi peace be upon
him these brothers can help you with
sources study circles may Allah bless
you and your family with knowledge and
guidance
I'm aware of that word so sure
and brother Noor says assalamualaikum
Brothers I'm from Somalia and love you
all for the sake of Allah may Allah
I mean
before we end off this stream uh I think
there's a beautiful overlap now between
actual gas brother of Allah and brother
Oscar
um so brother Abdullah do you have any
advice for the brother you know just
coming in tests now
um
can you move to the silence I don't want
to be abrupt and giving them advice um
in this particular regard directly
um too quickly
um
the advice of like the Messiah
is always to just to uh to take things
obviously as slow as possible and try to
focus more on definitely the five daily
prayers more more important than
anything and try to build that love and
connection towards your religion as much
as you can
um but obviously as the brother advised
through the super chat through the Seer
of Muhammad because the more you know
him
um the more you love him and this is
just inevitable you have you just love
him because the more you understand him
and also the Quran because the speech of
Allah is the greatest speech
um to ever be revealed to Mankind and
it's perfect and it doesn't have
anything missing from it and while
saying that as well is
and this is a general productivity
concept and this is just a general like
Islamic concept as well is that don't
try out too much try remove more and
what I mean by that is we should all
reflect on our lives and think what bad
habits do I have that I can remove so I
can make spaces for new habits sometimes
what happens is we try to add habits and
that's what actually reduces our
discipline because we have other bad
habits which cause friction between
these habits so for example like let's
say you want to wake up in the morning
forget trying to wake up early in the
morning focus on trying to stop sleeping
late and then naturally you wake up in
the morning so if you can take that
concept and then apply it to your
religion and think you know what like
you said masha'allah you've already
taken the step to not listen to music
that's going to open now the doors to
Quran because some people what they do
is they'll try this into Quran but then
they listen to music and that takes them
away from the Quran whereas if they just
stop listening to music they'll be
forced or they'll love to listen to the
Quran so if you do that towards the
beginning of your journey what you're
doing is purifying yourself and making
space for all of the worship and all of
the knowledge that you're going to
um partake in sha Allah and doing it
that way will not feel as overwhelming
as trying to research so many things
um from from so many different angles
and that would just generally be like my
advice to people whoever in the
productive life or just in your Islamic
life which is also a productive life as
well so
yeah thank you
you're welcome
and that's that advice does not just go
for brother Oscar it's also for me for
on help for all you guys at home
inshallah and I'm sure if her brother
Abdullah himself too
may Allah bless all the people who
attended inshallah do you guys have any
last words for the people watching
before we end the Stream
no
that's it five all right for me and I
was just gonna say Obviously thank you
guys for um having me on your stream
um for as well like being good
companionship obviously this is whilst
you guys are interviewing me at the end
of the day this is also a companionship
between us
um alhamdulillah we've built um a small
band and it's the beginning of abundance
and also in two different countries
alhamdulillah being brought together by
the benefit of the internet and uh
inshallah everyone has benefited from uh
from this Amela bless your work and
increase you guys in goodness and keep
you firm upon your sincerity because one
of the hardest things to do in this uh
Road of yours is to be as sincere as you
can and both for myself and yourselves
um so yeah just keep up the hard work
insha Allah may Allah bless you all with
what's best for you and protect you from
that which may harm you
I mean uh for you as well I do want to
give a shout out to fire because he's
the one that like uh messaged me and
everything so I want to give a shout out
to fire definitely definitely he's up
now
organizing everything can be in like a
backbone for you guys as well
for the entire chat if y'all are
watching right now if y'all misfired
spam the chat section with hashtags
we're gonna make this a thing until he
comes back inshallah and
with that being said
all right
foreign